Hello. And welcome to another episode of Rawkode
live. I am your host Rawkode.
Today, we're going to try and write a
kubectl plugin to rectify a very major wrongdoing
in the Kubernetes ecosystem.
We will talk a little bit about that
in just a moment. First, I want to
introduce my friend and host for today, our
co host, I guess, Matt. Hey, How's it
going?
Hey. Not bad. Thanks. Not bad. Awesome. Do
you wanna give us the quick
elevator pitch, who you are, what you do,
and why you're here?
Sure.
Pitch means I'm selling something. I don't know
why I'm selling.
I'd only start these with used to be
a software engineer. But you're about to see
my code, so I'm probably not gonna say
that. I I used to be a software
engineer. Yeah. No. I'm Matt. I I guess
I do DevOps and Kubernetes stuff.
I used to be a software engineer, then
I got into the whole containers and cloud
and Kubernetes thing.
I had a bit of a fascination with
Istio for a couple years.
Yeah. Just kinda hang around.
I've worked a bit like big big companies
and small, and and my last role was
head of platform running a team to build
a, you know, your your classic cloud native
platform for a for a fintech company.
Nice.
Well, I think, I mean, we've known each
other a while now. Probably, I think it
was true, the Kubernetes community.
I think, know, it's safe to say we're
both well versed. We use it almost daily,
if not every day, many times a day.
And
I think we decided to patch this episode
or talk about this episode just for me
ranting on Twitter
about the verb and known ordering of the
cube control command. And I I if I
remember correctly, you had an agreement with me.
Right? Like, we we were both firmly in
the camp that it's wrong.
I think we were both firmly in the
camp that it's wrong. And then I started
saying all of these things. Oh, you know,
when I was a young thing,
when I was at some some gray beard
taught me from software engineer. Right? If you're
gonna name a method because I started off
doing embedded c, and there's no
classes or anything. Right? So you end up
with sort of these these massive long function
names like it's basically package underscore component underscore
something underscore something.
And there was this perennial argument, and Graybeard
put his foot down in that first place
and said, no. It's noun noun noun noun
verb. Because you might have a bunch of
nouns. You might be in a in a
hierarchy that you'd use packages and classes for
in another language. You know, you might have
a a tree you might be in a
tree iterator. Both of those are nouns, but
then at the end, it's like get, set,
delete, create. You know? So that's that's your
verb. So I think I said, yeah, kubectl
should be maybe I'm jumping ahead, but I
think we both we both agreed it was
wrong. We both had different ideas for what
write looked like.
Yeah. So
for me, I mean, again, I spent a
lot of time in my command line. I'm
gonna assume that people working with Kubernetes generally
are anyway. You know, we are using kubectl
and helm and kind and all of these
other other tools
and I just always find it really frustrating
that I have to do
verb noun and then when I want to
change or do something else with a noun
and I got to delete twice and then
recompose my entire command and it just it
doesn't have that flow, that ergonomics that I
really want from a command line application. And
we we seem to be in a situation
where just all of the tools are now
doing this, where it's kubectl get pods and
then if you want to you know do
something else with that pod, you have to,
I guess we should show it, right? I'm
never
gonna be able to articulate it. Yeah, maybe
we should. So
let's see, let's
do my screen share.
So there's my my readme, we're starting from
nothing today.
What am I doing? I have no idea.
I do Type control.
Get pods. I was
faffing around with this cluster earlier, so there's
some random resources here.
But now if I want to do anything
else with this, I have to
delete two words.
Yep. Change.
And
the ergonomics don't feel right.
I mean, feel like I should be doing
pods get pods
to scrape
and just really working with that flow.
Your terminal's slightly off the bottom of the
screen there by the way.
It
is for me. Just that line you're typing
on.
Alrighty.
Let's see if I can change that. Yes,
I can.
So crop fell off. There. Now you just
get everything. Yeah.
Cool.
Yes. I agree. I mean, yeah, you okay.
You look at a deployment and then you're
like, right. It's, you know, it's done its
thing, but the why still my program still
isn't running, so you go and change,
you know, deployments to replica sets and then
replica sets to pods, maybe. But, yeah, more
often I end up listing pods,
describing a pod, doing get dash o YAML
on a pod.
Even things like logs, you wanna look at
the logs. You know? I mean, yes, there's
there's obviously solutions to all of this. You
know? Z Shell's got some some nice crazy
syntax involving a lot of exclamation marks where
you can go and change. But, you know,
other words in a in a previous command,
and you could learn all of your read
line stuff to, like, navigate around those words.
But it's not
what was that really good talk by Rich?
Whatever his name is. You know, simple is
not easy. Like, it's it's possible, and if
it's in your muscle memory, then it's easy.
But it's not simple, it's not intuitive, it's
not discoverable, it's not the same as the
other tools that you use.
Yeah. Definitely.
So I think
we've explained, we've set the we've set the
challenge, right? We've explained why we don't like
the way it works right now.
And Kubernetes are particularly kube control does provide
ways for us to extend the command.
It has this concept of a plugin, very
similar to the way that get plugins work.
You can find this documentation on the Kubernetes
website.
And if you're not familiar with how get
plugins work, all you really need to do
is have another command available on in your
path that starts with kubectl dash forget is
get dash. And anything after that then becomes
a new sub command and the kubectl command
and it executes it.
Nice and simple.
So we're gonna just really start with the
most crudest approach that think we're gonna that
we can get away with here and that's
just use a little bit of bash.
I guess we'll start with the developer friendly
hello world equivalent and then we'll see if
we can actually try and fulfill the verb
and noun swap page.
And then we also want to take a
look at using crew as a way to
provide
a crew as a plug in manager for
control that would make it easier for other
people to install this plug in and get
the benefits of this.
Easy. Right? Easy.
I mean, there's no it's no CNI. There's
no as you say, we can just dump
a binary on the path. We don't have
to implement a gRPC interface over loop back.
Nobody's gonna fork exec us with some, like,
great crazy,
you know, crazy set of arguments. Like, I
yeah. It could be. I tried to extend
I was trying to extend the scheduler last
week, and I'm thankful for this interface, me
tell you.
Alright. Okay. Good.
Let's just get started.
You just go down this page, there is
this really
nice, not nice, a very simple example for
bash that we're just gonna Oh, cheers. Cheers,
Tim Hawken. That's done.
We're just gonna steal this.
We're gonna start with a fail. And then
we have a live share here, which means
that I should call this kubectl.
We'll call it pods for now.
And you should be able to see this,
right?
Because the live share and can you type?
Give me a give me something.
42. There we go. Right. Perfect. Mhmm.
Now don't delete it. Oh, I didn't.
What the hell?
Yeah. Sorry.
Not off to a good start. Right.
So,
no, I I I really
don't care about argument handling right now.
I I really just want to show how
simple it is
to get started. So we just say, hey,
I'm a plugin named kubectl pods,
we save the script.
Now because this is the bash script, we
do need to make it executable.
Yeah. I'm
just gonna symlink this directly into my path.
I was gonna say.
And this is where I show my
my twenty years of Linux knowledge and still
can't remember if it's a target.
It's source first. Source first. Yeah. It's source
first. I should put a path on it.
So user
local.
Means I should now
have access.
Oh, it does not.
No. Try it. You might need hash dash
r just to make your shell
realize.
Oh, wrong one. Oh, no. Because it's got
a dot s h on it. Okay. So.
This is the wrong way around.
Is it? Did I get it wrong?
Oh, no. Oh, no. I need the fill
path. Okay. So. You you need to I
didn't think you did. I almost said something.
Yeah.
I thought it would work it out. Okay.
So, let's do this. And we actually want
to make it available just as pods.
Alright. Let's see how's that looking. We might
need a should bang line
to make it execute properly. Oh, yeah, of
course. We have one.
Oh, we do have one. We have bad
one. So,
user ben env bash.
Okay. Now we have a bearish event.
Cool.
If we run kubectl Should be should be
done then. Pods.
Which means,
because this is all really simple.
Mhmm. We now can have we now have
a new subcommand on. Done. Alright. Thanks. See
you later. I honestly I thought we'd be
fighting go dot mod files for like an
hour. Like this is really cool.
I mean,
think we're gonna be able to get quite
far with our really crude bash version
of this and well actually not because we're
trying to
here's a challenge,
We're gonna need a different one of these
bash scripts for each of the nouns that
we want to be able to drop in
as a sub command because we don't have
that encapsulation of a sub command. Oh, hadn't
thought of that. But we'll make it work
for for pods and maybe deployments and then
hopefully people will give us some pull request
with other with other names because I don't
know. Could we make our lives a bit
easier and just just call our plug in
like foo and then you you could literally
shell alias like kubectl to kubectl foo.
That's a good idea. Or maybe
we'll have a
I'm assuming we can just drop in as
many of these batch scripts as we want.
So we can have Oh, nice. Deployment replica
sets and then have an encapsulator code through
that people can use as an alias, maybe.
Anyway,
one one problem at a time, Matt. Alright.
Yeah. Fair. Good point. Good point.
So as
far as our crude implementation goes,
all we really wanna be able to do
is is execute
something
pods
that. Alright?
Where Yeah. Get pods.
So, I mean, I don't wanna sound too
confident, but that
oh, no. No. Get yeah. Get pods. Okay.
But how do I know I want to
get? So, actually, this goes here.
So, I'm trying to find a tweet where
I sort of suggested this grammar. Like, I
can't.
But I think it was something like
we we were changing the noun and verbal
audition. It was something like pods get
name
and then the arguments. And I think I
suggested, you know, as a as a bonus,
you could leave more and more
of those latter parts off.
So, you know, QPCT or pods would would
do a list essentially, like a like a
get. Yeah. You propose bringing the names based
into the
into the mix as well. We talked about
providing defaults
if you're got the cube counter. But right
now, let's let's assume that we wanna be
able to run cube control
pods get dash
a. Right? So we wanna do all namespace.
Yeah. So what we really want is to
take the first parameter and that's I don't
think this is the right bash syntax. This
is I've made this up.
No, that's
that yeah, that's not.
I was I I think there's something like
that, like where you say, maybe that's just
my ghost slipping through, like, hey, it's gonna
be the rest of the slice that's after
the first So let's try and get that
to work then. Yeah. Some something yeah. I
agree. That'll swap.
Because I mean, don't wanna be writing a
parser in bash.
No.
So let's see. Let's clutch it for now.
Bash array syntax. So
the the old fact the correct way to
do it old fashioned was
shift.
But, yeah, bash four, bash five, you've probably
got some nice erase syntax.
Yeah. Let's see. What have we got? Well,
we can definitely do it. We we should
probably do it with shift and stuff.
Do you wanna look at that? I'll knock
up, like, s h compatible something
in case we need it. Yeah. Okay. So
what you're suggesting is we actually say command
equals
and we're gonna shift this
and then extra or
else. Yeah. Basically. Okay. Yeah. You know that.
Yeah. Yeah. So
I I don't even remember the right syntax
here, but I'm gonna work it out. So
Yeah. It's not quite shift. It'll be command
equals one
and then shift does its own command, basically.
Shift just pops pops that queue.
I don't think you need an argument to
shift. I think shift literally just punch all
the positional arguments by one. Oh, really? There
we go. Yeah. I think so. You think
And then you can use and then and
then you can use app for it. Yeah.
You
know what? How do we test it? Well,
we run it in production. So let's see.
Pause. Get.
Oh. Come on. Yeah.
We're done. I mean We're done. We're done.
We're literally done. Should we default
so I think
we
can say if
one isn't provided,
I need to default to get. What are
you typing?
Do I have to save in Versus Code?
Oh, so you wanna be able to run
just a key I think literally just pods.
Yeah.
Okay. I like it. But I could also
do pods describe
and then pass n one and that should
still work. So good. I'm
already loving this plugin. I've got this I'm
actually yeah. This is so I've got about
three pages worth of shell aliases. I've I've
got a bash RC snippet. It's just got
so much. Like I've got bash functions that
auto generate like shell aliases. Like that's that's
how much I use Kube CTL. And this
is already better. I'm I'm pretty hungry.
Right. So now we can try and show
off the workflow that we actually want. We're
like, hey, well I just wanna be able
to push up and I wanted to scrape
this resource.
Like and I'm not deleting
any words to be able to do this.
That's awesome.
I mean, I didn't think we would get
this far in an hour and a half
and we've done it.
Did we say
what so so what is the workflow then?
What's the sort of what's the key user
journey through this? Because I often find that
I I'll get them and I'll end up
describing one like that. And then the next
thing I'll probably end up doing is like
a get dash o yaml.
Yeah, so generally you're right. So what I
I think I'm just gonna repeat exactly what
you said but I I do a lot
of pods alright, okay.
Oops.
And I said okay, what's what's wrong with
this pod and then if there's nothing here
then I would say okay, well I actually
let's
get NGINX one, it's not copied to my
buffer anymore.
Let's see if we can
find a bash way to handle that.
And then dash o. Yeah.
So the get isn't a default anymore either
because engine Right. Because yeah.
But still, I still like where this is
going, so. Yeah. No. No. Definitely. I just
wonder whether without verb
really does wanna go on the end because
I think that's what I suggested because I
was like, noun noun noun. Because I think
I I think I suggested QCTR namespace
name
verb.
No. I'm not saying that's what like, thinking
about it, I don't I think the namespace
should still just be a flag,
and that's maybe not
the most but what that would let you
do is go back up and literally just
just change the verb. So we're like, oh,
yeah. That one, it's broken. It's wedged. You
know? Delete.
Because there, I often just use delete just
to cycle. I push a new image in
another terminal from the code I'm writing and
then do a delete. Yeah. So,
what you're proposing is where we would actually
quite like the syntax where we have this
and we say describe and when that goes
together what we want, we say okay, let's
get the logs or maybe we want more
information
and but then I think we're in a
situation where we need to be able to
understand when this is a verb and when
it's
when when it's a target.
Right? Because we still wanna be able to
do pods
get
or
do we? Well, I think if we just
think if we just say pods,
well, pods
get will just work because you can just
say pods. And do we ever wanna just
do pods deletes
for all of them? We probably don't. Pods
create, edit, it doesn't make sense. But what
if I wanna do a label selector where
it's get me all of the pods where
app equals nginx,
which right
now Two.
Well, NGINX one, I think I've got it
called.
Well, that would work, but
that's no long, I mean, if we inject
some pod name here, we lose the ability
to do that.
So as much as I like your idea
of having that fluid interface where we do
have the name followed by some command to
an act on a target,
being able to understand when we actually need
to escape out for that, I think would
be quite a challenge.
Unless we unless we allow lists some specific
commands like get or etcetera.
Right. Yeah. I was thinking the name would
always be there but you're right that like
label selectors are are
very often used as a stand in for
a name on there. Yeah. And that does
make it very I'd have to wrap my
brain for far too much like you do
computer science
for whether this grammar's ambiguous or not. And
we don't really were running a parser in
Bash anyway. Yeah. Okay. No. Let's stick with
this. I'm really I'm I'm pretty happy. Well,
let me let me double advocate myself here.
What if we
check for the dash?
What if we check for flags?
And that means that we're working on no
name basis and anything else we would assume
is a name.
Yeah. Would there ever be a reason to
type
anything after pods that's not a name that
isn't a flag?
Mean what what do you do with a
list? Do you watch? You list dash w
dash l like
maybe
we're okay?
Yeah. There's no it doesn't take any other,
you know, non flag arguments, does it? It
doesn't take any other
I forgot what Python calls them. Other than
the command and the name.
Let's try it.
Let's try it. Let's try and make this
work. So what we wanna see now and
let me just sort of quote this out
a little bit is before we go shifting
and getting a command, we wanna establish
is the first parameter
a flag.
If so,
then what we're gonna say is that
something.
Otherwise, it's a Yeah.
If
it's a flag, I guess.
Now I'm trying to work out, do we
ever need to send flags to anything that's
not a get because what we're saying is
we are gonna assume that it's all worth
a get.
What if we wanna delete? I
don't think we do need to assume because
if we're rearranging them then you can just
put the verb on me. The get just
goes on the end. But if we
no. But if I wanna delete all pods
right now,
then it would be pods delete
all.
We would assume this is the name of
a pod. Does that work?
Yeah.
Is the capital a not all namespaces?
Need you need to say it's all, isn't
it? It's literally pods delete.
But which is a flag?
But the delete becomes before the flags. Are
are you are we now suggesting that, hey,
actually what we want to do is all
delete?
Yeah. It's not the most ergonomic thing, is
it?
Who does I think that write in the
the cube control wrongs be so complicated. So
Maybe the guys who wrote it, the people
who wrote it knew what they were doing.
Maybe it should just be delete.
Right. No. That's I'm I'm not gonna not
sticking with that. Should we maybe just try
and do this for GET?
Because I I mean, I do not delete
all pods that off. I think I'm happy
if this thing gives me some shortcuts. I
I I'm happy if this does not completely
replace Kube CTL, you see what I mean.
If it's useful shortcuts, and then if this
doesn't cover it, as long as it doesn't
do the wrong thing, as long as it
doesn't do anything dangerous, it just goes, I
don't know what that is.
Then I just go back to Kube CTL.
I don't know what you think. I think
I'd be happy with that.
Okay. Well, let's just make sure that we
have, you know, the target workflow that we
started with. Make sure that works. That's, I
mean, that to me is all that's important.
Is this is the ability to do pods,
delete,
get,
describe
and I really wanna make logs work here
too.
Okay.
So even though I know you can
get logs of other resources.
Does that work at the moment?
So it works with what we've Maybe we
actually should. Well, okay. You're right. Okay. So,
pods.
Just gonna Okay. Because we went in a
rabbit hole where we're like, oh, but the
name should come before so that I only
need to then do up Yeah. Delete.
The the way it is, it actually works
very nicely.
You're so annoying. Anyway, right.
That way it was me that suggested the
rabbit hole, actually I'm like, what we've got
what we've got works. Yeah. So now if
I wanna change this to be logs, I
am going back before this target. Yeah.
That's what I mean.
What if mean So we could swap.
The
problem with swapping them is the
yeah. Sometimes you don't wanna give a name,
sometimes you wanna give flags. I mean, we
can always just encourage.
Well, I can never remember that syntax, but
yeah, sure.
I I got something wrong, something like that
though.
But then that would work if I was
using the original syntax. Right? So like,
we still wanna identify
something cool about this interface.
So I I know why we tried to
put the command after the thing,
but it's gonna be tricky.
So this is this is speed one. Right?
We're just having a bit of Yeah. This
is okay.
Maybe we try to extend this to deployments
and stuff and then maybe we try and
get it up in crew. Maybe that's what
we should look at first.
Because once we got the framework, I mean,
somebody could come along and I mean, we
shouldn't be leaving this in bash. Right? We
probably should write it in a real language.
Why?
Yeah. Maybe we we maybe At which point,
we lean on a library. At which point,
we literally lean on, like, a a parser
library. Right? We we yak or whatever the
equivalent is for Go.
Okay.
So,
there's something we've not tackled.
KP
get
won't work anymore. So it gives them like,
because remember all the resources have aliases like
pods Oh, they do, don't you? Most of
them, yeah. Deploy, deploys, deployment.
Yeah.
Is that not gonna
Well, we would to
make sure. Yeah. Maybe we should jump to
crew now. Maybe crew provides some facility for
them injecting this with multiple names. I'm not
sure. I've never done this before either. So
Yeah. Okay. But if we can have to
say, take this fail and stick it in
the path as kubectl pods, kubectl po, kubectl
whatever.
Yeah. Either crew just just literally dumps out
multiple siblings or maybe even kubectl
has a
a metadata file. Like, they can find a
JSON file on the same path that tells
the aliases or something. Alright. So let's Okay.
Work
out what crew is.
Yeah. I assumed it did more, but maybe
it doesn't.
So discover plugins, install them on your machine
and keep them up to date.
So
the better no, that'll be for developing crew
itself.
No, distributing plugin. Okay.
Plugin naming game, best practices, we can skip
all that.
Best practices is not for us. No.
Okay. So, shall we just jump straight to
the manifest?
See what this is. Okay. Right. Okay. So
you do give it a manifest.
Of course, it's of course, it's Kubernetes style
API. Of course.
So let's call this crew.
Oh,
hates me today.
Rename
crew
dot yaml.
Alright.
So
crew Google container tools,
plugin.
The name must match the file name of
the manifest.
Right?
So we call this
the noun verb plugin.
Which means I need to rename my file.
Mhmm.
To be known
verb.
Thank you comment.
Version.
Yep. Zero zero one seems about right. Maybe
that's too mature. Alpha one. Alpha.
Yep.
Homepage.
Sure. Why not? Rawkode,
cube control,
and verb.
Description,
bringing
sanity
and composable
composability
to keep control.
I mean, don't wanna offer too much but
I feel that we are I was gonna
say important mission. Aspirational.
Let's see if I can learn to spell.
Maybe
that's just not a word.
As as for today.
Maybe you can't compose compose that stem and
suffix. Bring insanity and compose.
I like it. Like that we've composed
a fake word. Yeah. Yeah. I think it's
like I like the irony, we should keep
it.
Alright description.
Thanks.
Not gonna worry about that. Okay. The platforms
should work on anything that's portable POSIX compatible
bash scripts. See? Exactly.
Yeah. Go with requires to compare this multiple
times. Now we are We're even using user
user bin m. Mean, we're Yeah. Safe.
We'll even work on next, which is good.
Yeah.
URI.
Oh, we haven't really
Okay. So they're using GitHub. Yeah. They're using
GitHub releases.
That's fair enough. And there we go. We
have the ability to deploy the fails.
Oh, we we could have used that.
Yeah. Dot slash. I wonder where it's I
assume it prefixes that path.
A bin specifies the path of plug in
executable. Oh, amongst alt right.
Oh.
So I think what it's
doing is I think those are passed within,
like, a sandbox,
and then that bin key at the bottom
is telling it which one to symlink into
user local.
Does that mean we need a manifest for
every
sub command?
It doesn't look like it.
Well, I mean, that's not gonna work.
No. It's
So we would have to provide the cube
control known plug in, which then you'd have
to alias cube control known to cube control.
We we probably would have to go down
that encapsulated
route to provide this. That's all I can
think of at the moment. The problem with
that is it then needs to cover the
full surface area of cube control.
It can't just be shortcuts unless
it just unless we write the, quote, unquote,
parser fairly well so that it just like,
if it doesn't recognize the sequence, it bails
out and it calls
underlying cube control with exactly the set of
arguments you've given it.
Well, I I think it I I don't
think we need a parser. I mean, all
we're doing is swapping the first argument around.
I mean, we we would have to inject
something in here. So like,
it would be That's why it's
yeah.
So that's why it's quote unquote parser. Quote
unquote parser. Okay. I'm just thinking if you
alias
kubectl two, kubectl noun verb,
kubectl noun verb then has to understand everything
you could ever possibly pass to kubectl. Right?
Either understand it or realize that it doesn't
understand it and call the underlying one. I
mean, the only constraint on people using this
program would be that you no longer could
put your name as base in the start.
You would have to always do pods get
and then do flags so that it can
swap these two around.
But there's other weird stuff on there's like
QCTL API resources. Right? And
all of these other weird little commands that
you forget.
Exec
and all of that stuff that don't follow
this because they're not CRUD operations.
There's all there's all the basically, the RPC
methods.
Yeah.
It's getting more complicated than I was hoping
for, wasn't it? So I've got, I've got
k. I use KubeCTL so much. I've got
k alias to KubeCTL. Maybe
we just alias k or KNV
to KubeCTL noun verb. And then that's your
set of shortcuts
right on your fingertips.
Well, yeah.
Okay. So this is a bit of fun
to understand how crew works anyway. Right? I
mean, we're not actually trying to
to solve this problem. I mean, I do
wanna make my life a little bit easier.
So You might not be.
Yeah. No. I'm getting I'm getting carried away.
Should we just fork cube control and just
fix it?
Okay.
What what should we learn next? Okay. Maybe
it just does pods for now. Should we
should we try to publish
it? Let's just publish it and see if
we can install it through crew.
That would be really cool. I'll I'll try
to install it over here. Yeah. That'd be
really cool. Okay. Let's do that.
So this is just our pods helper, we
don't need to solve anything else. We can,
you know if we're feeling nice, we'll add
deployments
services. The basic ones, right? Nobody won't handle
any CRDs, custom resources or special commands. So,
that means we have our noun verb here.
So I'm I'm gonna have to push this
to get hub. So we need a repository,
we need a release, so we need a
tag and then we'll need to fill in
these values. So,
like all good new projects,
get in it.
I thought that was the default now. Get
in it.
There it is. What did it say?
Oh, no. I have to set config global
init. Alright. You just get it's global config.
Okay. Get init. There we go.
And
get at
our readme, which has nothing,
and our alias, our sub command.
Let's get that pushed up first and tag
it.
So, feat fixing
the pod insanity.
I'm loving the hyperbole with this episode. I've
got It's great, isn't it?
Keep con keynote right here.
We fixed it. We saved you. All we
saved everybody a hundred thousand keystrokes a year.
Exactly.
Right. And you're positive. What's that? Oh, is
that just the theme selector? I thought it
was a new feature. Okay.
Cube CTL
noun
verb.
I'm hoping there's something in the crew syntax
where we can deploy multiple plugins in a
single, but
if not, I'll be able to plug later.
So this is gonna be public,
you don't wanna know,
and
go.
Let's copy this.
PERSH origin main.
Yeah.
Fingerprint.
Now
we wanna tag this.
0Dot0Dot1AlphaAlpha1.
It's hyperbole and then it's
straight up fraud, which would be calling this
a v one.
Yeah. You're right.
Push the tag
and let's refresh this. So we should have
new release.
I've
never done a release before.
Zero.
Oh, yeah. No. It's cool. Yeah. You see
that drop pick that from the drop down.
And it should make it from the yeah.
It should make it from that tag.
Yeah. There you go. So on the left
on the right is the release name. On
the left is the the tag it's associated
with.
They just copy the length of this tarzip.
Oh, yeah. I was thinking we would actually
have to make that release artifact, but it's
what we want is exactly just the zip
content to that repo. Right?
Yeah. I wanted the shaft, so let's just
download that.
Curl FSSL.
Yeah.
Did
anything come down? Nothing came down.
TTZ.
There we go.
Yeah,
what?
I would learn how to set it just
to Sha256.
Sha 2 5 6. Yeah, exactly.
I'm
not But now I'm gonna learn how to
work my Mac. Let's just see what gives
me then. What
is that? What does the man page say
that is?
5.thirty.
Print or check Shasms.
Oh, so we can specify the algorithm default.
We're getting one. Yeah. We don't want sha
one here. Right? We want a 256 probably.
We want it to specified. Yeah. Did. Okay.
Yeah. So
DashA256.
I'm just intrigued. I'm gonna look it up
now. That looks better. Here we go. Oh,
I've got a sha two five six on
my Mac.
I'm sure it's probably installed.
Like I I took the winter
break just to wipe this thing and like
rebuild my dot file. All my dot files
are up in Linux. I've been using Linux
since I was 16 and this new role,
they gave me a Mac and I've been
I've been trying to make the best of
it, shall we say.
I'm impressed you've stayed off because I yeah.
I've been using Linux for about the same
amount of time. I've got my I think
we're about the same age. I got my
dot files in in gits, right, on GitHub.
It's all beautiful. And then, yeah, I've I've
not been able to to resist the Macs
for for so long. Companies keep giving me
them. So many of my dot files are
now full of if I was Darwin.
Do something do something weird.
Yep.
Alright. Let's let's get this working. So we're
almost there. Can feel it. So from
I'm assuming this plugin probably just has a
directory unlike ours. Right? So let's just check
that out.
When in doubt, pull up the repo.
There we go. I'm assuming they've got a
directory called no, they don't.
That's annoying. No. I think it's
Well, this is fine, right? Because it's literally
just gonna be in the I I assume
they just extract the zip into the sandbox
directory. Look at that. There's no bin file.
It's just from star.
Nice.
Okay.
I feel like we're onto a winner here.
So Yeah. This might work. We might have
to read the docs, but let's try it.
So fails from to.
Why is not gonna be able to fix
that?
There we go.
And we just want all
Oh, so I think it's extracting it into
this directory, isn't it? That's what's happening. Okay,
so kubectl
Oh yeah, okay. And verb star star
dot, just describe the dot SH's and stick
them into whatever the dot is
and see if we can get away with
it.
Yeah.
That may be enough.
So I'm gonna I'm feeling brave so
Just on git, I don't know, let's let's
work it out.
I wonder if our zip's got a prefix
in it the way GitHub makes it. We'll
find out. So we're gonna add the crew
manifest.
We're gonna tag us as alpha two and
we're gonna push everything
and create a new release. Is there a
way for me just to create
releases from tags? Is that not something GitHub
does?
Not out of way. GitHub actions would be
the way to set that up.
Not out of the box.
Okay.
New
alpha two target man
pre release publish.
So normally, obviously, you'd actually have to make
those. It it zips up the sources those
two like default assets and obviously you normally
actually have to do like a build step.
Right?
And kind of publish assets
there. Yeah. But yeah, we get we get
we get to win because we've just got
just the interpreted code is what we want.
I feel that we got quite lucky by
just saying let's hack this together and the
shell script instead of actually Yeah. Go because
that was not the default. Yeah. It was.
Yeah. I was like, we're gonna have to,
you know, we're have to import all the
client go packages, call it's KubeCTL packages, sorry,
call it's internal API, you know, find it's
four kit, find it's parser, rip it out.
And I was gonna spend all weekend like,
preparing for this and then I was too
busy.
Here we are. I think we're we're on
to a winner here. So we now have
alpha two now.
How do we tell crew about it? So
let's Yeah. How do we actually publish this
to their registry?
And are they gonna let us? I mean
Yeah. I mean, we maybe have to you
we probably have to raise a PR on
k slash k or something to be like
acknowledged.
Oh, I don't think it'll be KK shit.
I mean, well Maybe not KK. Testing plugin.
Let's do local. Right? There we go. Yeah.
Okay.
I need okay.
I don't even think I have do I
have crew? No. So let's if if you
got crew.
It's Maybe install another or something.
We're about to find out. Maybe
install another plug in just to find out
where it and then use which to find
out where it puts it, so we can
change ours as being actually sort of installed.
Alright. Zero four o, that looks like a
Kubernetes project, so.
Yeah. I've got a few of these plugins,
so.
Why is that not in my path?
Let's see if it is if I do
this.
Is it a plugin itself?
Or it is? Yeah, it is. Yeah, it
is.
And they go in Yeah, right. They go
in home
dot crew
bin is where they all end up. In
fact, it was right there in front of
me. Alright. Okay. So
install,
point it to our manifest.
Noun verb.
And then he's just specified archive.
Yeah, my guess.
Oh, we got an error. Ben has to
be set. That was not set on the
other plugin.
No. Which other plugin did you
find?
Or was it? And it's just Is this
a YAML schema thing?
They're on our v one alpha one.
We also Are you v one alpha one?
I don't know. Because that that repo hadn't
been touched for for three years.
Yeah.
Oh, David.
Terrible given.
Right. Fine.
Fine. Fine. Fine. Alright.
Let's see. They've added security.
Matt and Dave work around security.
Oh, look at that. There's an example patch
one. Perfect.
Oh, yeah. So they have this
Ben.
Should we should we get it working like
that for now? We can always
we can look at auto generating this stuff
or do you know, doing something Yeah. Was
just curious if they document
the field.
Yeah. Okay. So each platform requires path to
the plugin.
You would specify this.
It creates a symlink to that.
I mean,
Yes.
Because we're trying selected as much.
Be a bit more dangerous. Although, this is
an array. Right? So
Oh, it is. It wasn't. I I was
gonna say that, but I swear it wasn't
in that example we had.
If it's an array, that's awesome.
So we can see Yeah. Looking on my
machine, there's yeah. I've got I've got a
symlink farm and then I can see there's
basically a sandbox directory they all get extracted
into.
And it just wants the script,
which for us,
get to your pods.
I mean, we can clean up that name
and remove that. But for now, let's just
do this. I'm gonna
No. No. Let's just do that. Let's start
something. I don't I don't wanna Yeah. Yeah.
True.
Okay.
So that should make that happy.
Not quite
oh, yeah. It just wants this path. Okay.
URI has to be set.
Oh,
no. Oh, so the Ben has to come
in here. Okay. Got it. Got it. Got
it. Got it.
Well, I broke it.
Oh, no. Isn't it? Okay. So now we
need to change it to skip the first
two.
Maybe. I don't know what it sees.
I don't know how q c q c
c l might strip
one or both of them?
That's a good question. Let's do two
and then shift shift.
I assume that's right. Alright.
We could just just echo them.
Force.
If in doubt.
I am I gonna have to uninstall it
to reinstall it?
I can tell you where it puts it.
We could just replace the file.
Or bum the version number, maybe.
Is that why it's not installing it? I
didn't get a chance to read it. You
might be right.
This is alpha two anyway. Right? Yeah.
Maybe I just
can't say that. That's not gonna work.
Alright. Where's the where does it stick that
fail?
It sticks it in dot crew
store.
Wait. A bin is this. So that's the
symlink. The actual file
is in store.
Yeah. Store now verbs version. Alright. Okay. So
copy.
So hacky.
This is a
CD right here.
Which means we wanna try
oh, no. It worked. Alright. Okay. So That's
sweet. We can skip noun verbs, which means
we know probably can add
all the aliases for pods, POP deployments,
etcetera. And then
we
probably
what I'll do is I'll do alias
key and equals
cube control.
I'm thinking that's how I'm gonna run it
on my machine.
I turned on this new Z Shell thing
which does like expansion, which I'm really loving
right now.
Why did that not work?
Because that worked. Right? Oh, no. I've broken
it.
Yeah. What? Oh, noun verb, not noun verbs.
Okay. So
k n
pods.
Nice. Okay.
We have changed the world today. Oh, so
you were talking you were typing k n
and it did that?
Yeah. So mine's auto expands.
Right. Okay. I just didn't see So when
I hit space?
Do Very nice. L t
t t. Yeah. Okay. That's nice. Oh, must
have them configured not to auto spent. Yeah.
I started I've been really working on my
Z Shell plugins
lately.
That's really nice.
Yeah. And if I do a key Cool.
Pod six bands too. Right. Okay.
We have a comment from someone.
It must be really weird for anyone who's
tuned in late. I'm really sorry, Alex.
Because this is a bit of a wild
one.
Yeah. Fuck it. We'll explain it again.
Yeah. I mean, we've got description somewhere. Right?
I I didn't add one because I had
no idea how to describe what the hell
we were trying to do. We're we're trying
to fix a wrong in the world which
is where you have to do pods
and then delete two words and then describe
your pods where we actually feel that it's
more ergonomically correct or enjoyable to do pods,
get,
describe,
etcetera.
So we're trying to make that work for
a plugin.
And I've been really,
know Matt has said, yes, we are trying
to fix this problem. But at the same
time we're using it as an excuse a
to catch up. No. No. Haven't. Because we've
not seen each other in a while and
this is the closest we're getting. And at
the same time also we're learning how to
keep control plugins work etcetera. So it's it's
more of a just fun casual episode.
Oh, we are. I keep trying to over
engineer it and yeah, David keeps pulling me
back.
He's just been like, okay. Maybe I'll skip
this one. Good call. Good call. Anyway,
so we're in a position now where we
we have it working.
Yeah. We've written this No, this is Crew
manifest.
You didn't let me cowboy it with v
one alpha one. Right. But it probably worked
out for the best because now we know
we can actually specify this multiple times, which
is
a little weird because Oh, right. That's how
you meant to do multi arch stuff if
you need to ship two different binaries.
Yeah. But we can probably just abuse that.
Right? They can all say Linux.
I think.
Because now we've changed the way that this
works. Right? Like,
bear with me here. So
no, don't worry, it's just a read me,
who cares.
We could probably make this an entry point
because we tried to make it work as
cube pods but the plugin system is actually
now force us down the noun verb sting.
So we need the alias which means this
doesn't necessarily have to be cube control pods.
This can be
Oh yeah, we can totally switch. We can
switch on our V two. Yeah.
We can
work out the get. We can also work
out the
noun.
Yeah.
It's just one.
We don't want a default there.
Is it one? Is one not known Oh
no no, one sorry, what's gonna be known
first. So this is just three and we're
not gonna let them have a default there.
We're not gonna
support that. And then we can note another
shift and what we're seeing is is the
pods becomes
known and I actually prefer this syntax. I
don't know why I didn't do that. And
then we pass everything else through. However, what
we can do shift to. Thanks Alex. Let
me pop that up.
I think we're learning. I'm learning actually.
So Idiomatically, you'd Idiomatically, you'd actually say
yeah. I guess you can do that.
Idiomatically,
what we'd actually do is you tend to
extract one. So you'd say
If that makes sense.
Okay. I'll go with it. But
we we need some special handling here. What
we
what you mentioned earlier was there are resources
like there are
things that aren't crud. So API resources,
exec,
should we build escape patches for that or
do we just assume that people are always
gonna use this as a special alias like
KN
rather than taking over a full K?
Right.
Maybe for now
What about like
exec and API resources
and
There's lot of them actually. Is CS one
or is it get CS? It's get CS,
right? Yeah. Yeah. It's cluster status, it's cluster
info, there's API extensions, API resources, API kinds.
Let's just throw them one warning as an
example
and then people start I mean, if people
are wild enough to start using this, they'll
add in the other edge cases. Right? So
what we're saying is if we run KN
and we're in the known verb syntax and
we do exec, we wanna warn on
noun.
Is that the wrong way around? Yeah. It's
actually known first so
and then Alright. Yeah. This was literally the
whole point in this, wasn't it?
Maybe, yeah, let's just okay. Let's yeah. You're
right. Let's make it easy. Let's check if
now it is not pods or deployments.
So case now.
I can never remember the best case statement.
Oh, it's the string and then a right
paren.
Copy. Yeah. Copy paste it. It's like that.
Okay. So what we're saying is if known
is in any of these
and
we'll just
okay. So
Yeah. And that seems to be like a
yeah. This is reg x, so
Yep. We're
gonna say
exec
API resources.
And we don't just wanna allow list pods
and deployments
and warn on everything else, and then just
allow list more things as we as we
know they work, as we support them.
Up to you. Up to you.
Okay. So let's support pod
pods
pull.
Yeah.
What we're gonna do here is override
noun
to be pods.
We'll always give it the full
version. Nice.
Anything else?
I know. We still want the wildcard. Hey.
Yeah. Hey,
don't do this. Exit one.
Ew.
This is bad.
Right.
Exit zero.
Then we're happy with the light.
I I don't think it's an error. We're
just in, hey, you you don't wanna do
this. Well, yeah. Fair. Well, I'm nice to
chaining it with all the yeah. We didn't
do anything wrong.
Yeah. No. I think we I think we
should to break pipelines stuff. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
So
let's test if this still works.
We need to modify this. So whenever we're
seeing that now we have this encapsulated group
where it's non verb.
We just drop it in
and
let's do my fancy copy again.
This is CD.
CP.
C p.
And then
verb.
Alright.
So that means key in.
Let's
remove
crew then.
You're gonna redeploy
it. I have no idea what I'm doing.
Hold on. Yeah. What are trying to do?
I wanna see
Oh, l n. What am I doing? L
s. So that noun verbs is going to
keep pods. So, yeah, we don't want that
to do that anymore. What we actually Oh,
right. No. Is Yeah.
Let's just remove it. So Let's see.
Crew bin. Let's just delete and see if
the crew install Do wanna remove it and
then install it? Yeah.
So let's just remove it from the store.
Yeah.
I know what I'm doing.
Oh, you know what? Screw you, crew.
Oh, because it's Maybe overkill.
Oh, yeah. And I've got alias.
What?
Source
Notebeard cannot be extracted into archive.
Can be found in extracted archive.
Because I blew out the inventory.
Is there like a crew in it? Oh,
no. We need to it's not in the
archive. We literally need to
do a git re do a git move,
push it to get up, do another release.
Alright. It's got the old name in it.
It's got the old name in the zip
file. Right? We need to do c I
before we do c d.
Let's
add let's make sure we confirm that delete.
We don't want the tarzip
commit.
Chore
refactor.
Git tag
alpha three.
Oh, let's update that fail.
Add
commit and no oh, I've got an alias
for that. Okay. Retag
it.
Stop judging me.
You didn't push it, it's fine.
Alright.
Let's get a release on the go. This
is this is my finest work. I was
gonna say this is dreadful but I don't
think I've ever written anything nicer than this,
so. I don't think I've ever been as
productive in another one. This is
this is this is a nice development ecosystem
to be fair. I was expecting this to
be nasty,
like extending the schedule is nasty or very
complicated,
like writing a a CRI plugin is very
complicated. This is really nice.
Yeah. Not been too bad, actually.
Okay. So I've got a really broken crew
directory right now, actually. So I think I
think you might wanna
burn it to the ground. Yeah.
So You have to reinstall crew now, of
course. Install.
Reinstall
crew.
I need an alias for that. I'm never
typing that again.
Oh, it doesn't like reinstall. I thought that
was a thing.
I think it might just be reinstall.
BrewLink crew should do it because that's that's
actually all you broke, isn't it?
I I don't know.
Let's just let it do that.
Alright. Let's see.
Install.
Of course, that doesn't work. This one.
It's alright. Okay. Brew.
Uninstall
crew.
I really shouldn't have blown away that whole
directory. I knew that was
getting carried away. I don't think it's that.
I think it's complaining about our archive.
Oh, right. It's complaining about the thing on
GitHub and saying it doesn't have QCTL noun
verb in it. Is it because it's noun
verbs?
Oh, you're probably right.
Sorry. Pair program. Oh, noun verb, verb. Is
noun verb at s h.
Should we call that archive and see what's
what's going on?
Well, I mean, this is wrong.
Right. We we need the shag again. Oh,
right. Oh, right. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm
gonna have to install some sort of new
quartiles or something like that I think for
that.
That shit is not the same, is it?
It shouldn't be. It shouldn't be.
Oh, I downloaded the wrong fail. I
it's totally amateur error. I'm really sorry.
Sorry. The pressure of typing is is real.
Is that too You never feel so smart
as when you're a pair programming Here we
go. Pair.
Because you're just the guy sitting there, like,
using 10% of your brain power, just picking
fault.
Don't worry. If this was reversed, I would
look like a complete idiot. You'd be like,
Matt, that's wrong. That's wrong.
So
yes. There's a weird
this doesn't
that's checking an egg problem here. Right? So
for me to update the code and tag
this as v four,
I would need to push that, release the
tag and then push
this with the shot. Oh, yeah.
How do you keep this on how do
you keep this under version control?
Maybe this doesn't maybe it shouldn't live in
our repository. Maybe someone's done that just for
the heck of it, and this lives in
the crew repo, and I'm just like
Yeah. Maybe.
But then you'd have to have right access
to the crew repo, or you'd need to
PR every time you wanted to do a
release.
We so we have this at my
we had this at my old place with
exactly this problem that was because we use
Bazel to do hermetic builds. You'd commit the
last of the code and lay the tag
to do a release,
and then it would go through CI,
and you then you'd end up with a
container image
with the char of the container image. Right?
And only then could you update your your
Helm files to tell Kubernetes to deploy it.
So you ended up with this weird double
commit because we didn't have a separate info
repo. I really wanted one, but the the
people who ran the the, you know, back
in microservices team
were so
set on their Bazel and their mono repo.
We would even the manifest needed to be
in there. So, yeah, we had exactly this
double commit to get the shark kind of
issue.
Yeah. So So I'm not we're we're not
gonna solve that today obviously. What I'm gonna
suggest is that I I mean we've already
pushed v v one alpha three and I'm
just gonna
do the current install
which should hopefully just use the archive.
Yeah. I've updated the shallowly, I'm not committing
that I'm not pushing it with an alpha
four and getting in a loop. I'm just
gonna do that. Right.
We didn't check the.
Okay. We're testing in process. So
my
very poor attempt at making this work work.
So let's run this locally. I mean
It's subjecting to that reject syntax. To what
is the bash reject syntax.
Yeah. I guess it's not that.
They're just doing
They've got square brackets for
character groups, which you'd expect.
Maybe you literally have to do it like
that, spell them out, and have them fall
through.
Because the double double semicolons, like, break. Right?
Yeah.
So we can now fall through. That'll get
it working. That'll get it. Pods
pod
Pull.
I'm not here to write vertices.
Life's too short.
And if I wanna test this, the easiest
way to do that would be
noun verb.
Although, now it's not gonna work because oh,
yeah. Noun. Well, it doesn't matter what that
Yeah.
Okay. So length seven.
Okay. So the fall through is not quite
right. Oh, wait. Wasn't it running the old
code then? Look at that error message again.
No. It's complaining about Got it. No. This
not really having a statement, I guess.
Was there an example of a fall Does
it need to be tapped in?
Did literally our
our statement literally be tapped in?
Oh.
As in, yeah, as in that?
And I think this something this wrong here
then. Right? So No. No. I think that's
fine.
I think that just needs to be indented
more than the and and the semicolons. I
think they just need to be dented more.
Yeah.
Try it.
Line seven.
Which one's seven then? That's weird. I mean,
if we let's I I don't mind if
it's duplicated for now. Yeah. Right. Yeah. Let's
make it work.
Okay.
Cool. So someone must have done this before.
Bash case multiple
matches.
Yeah.
Thanks, Google.
Was just trying to pay.
Oh, no. Wait. That's just the question. Yeah.
Like I did it all the time. Oh,
no. Okay. So just a piped.
So
let's try
pod
pull.
So we were just being a bit too
reg x y for it, I think, maybe.
We were being too good.
Okay. I get that. I get that a
lot. You get that a lot. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Cool. There we go.
And since we're gonna push another release,
let's make it a bit more useful.
So deployments.
Deployment.
Deploys.
Deploy.
Yeah.
I've never used anything shorter than deploy. Have
you? Does anybody else think you can.
Deploys.
I'm using my command here. Hold on. Is
there a way to get the aliases actually?
I've never don't know if I've done that.
Yeah. I think CTL API resources tells you
that. Oh,
yeah. Cool. So
Deploy.
Yeah. And then you could just pluralize.
I couldn't oh, that's okay. So deployments and
deploy. So ours is better because we're giving
you deployment and deployed.
So I
okay. And let's make sure that this is
bad works.
Exec,
thingy, majiggy.
Yeah. There we go.
Nice.
This is bad.
We
don't support
known
yet.
Nice.
PR's welcome.
Great minds.
Alright.
So
we need to add our
YAML, our cube control
and we wanna update the version
to be version four and we're not gonna
update this one
until we've done the release. So
commit bash m.
Fix use.
Ah,
bash.
Yeah. Fixed us rather than return.
We go tag it
alpha four,
don't need a force.
Push with tags.
I feel like we're almost there.
Which means now
we create the release.
Yes.
And that should be us.
New release.
This is v one alpha four.
Definitely a pre release. We had a couple
comments come in here, so DevOps directive said,
good stuff, fun over your morning coffee. Cool.
Good. This is a bit of a weird
one but I'm definitely enjoying myself I hope
that is true. Yeah
yeah. And
Adam says you're a little late. I mean
I feel sorry for the people who late
because this is wild but
you watched the Laravel Docker streams good work.
Oh thanks man, appreciate that. Okay so v
one alpha four
is out
which means now the crew installed didn't work
last time right? So hopefully we can just,
there must be some sort of update command
but first I'm gonna re download. We'd fix
that SHA right? Yeah.
Let's get our new SHA,
which is here.
Weird checking egg thing. I don't think we're
doing this right at all.
I think GitHub actions would let us do
this in one go.
So let's take a look at For example.
Yeah. It must have an upgrade command. Yeah.
That's an sure.
Upgrade install plugins to newer versions. Update local
copy of the plugin index. Let's try and
update. See if it pulls that.
Oh, wait. This is coming oh, yes. This
is coming from crew index repository. So we
do need to push the manifest to that.
But we pointing at a local oh, right.
So can we just give it a manifest?
Can we do a local update by pointing
it in a manifest still? Would it still
take that dash dash manifest?
No. So am I gonna have to uninstall
it and reinstall it?
That must be the Maybe. The local workflow,
I guess. So uninstall
noun verb.
Noun verbs. Like, it is in my install.
Reinstall.
Oh, yeah.
And now we could do Ken. Let's see
if we get our exact thing.
Although it said we don't support DHHF.
So it's wrong wrong interpretation. But
we do have.
Oh, no. Oh, no.
Oh, we literally shifted too many times.
Oh, this works locally.
Right. It worked locally, but there's an extra
argument in the front when you're running in
production. Right. Hot fix. We need a test
on this.
We need a hot fix. Alright. So we
need to push five and we need to
fix our bash so noun is
two.
We can fix this.
Oh, so that's properly right now actually.
And then this is
oh no. That's
it's still one.
We just need to shift. So shift two.
Oh, you did that when you were factoring.
That's what it was. Yeah. I did. I
broke it.
Okay. You think how many mice
Oh, and there's a bug.
Yeah.
So there is.
Okay.
So
And then we do a shift and get
okay. I'm confident with that. Are you confident?
It feels like a lot of shifts, but
okay. Okay.
So
we are pushing our new we need to
go to alpha five. This is a very
fast moving project. Definitely cloud native.
Multiple deployments a day.
Testing in production. I mean Unrefactored
mass
fix.
How?
Correct.
Push with tax. We're almost there. So, you
got the muscle memory for this now. I
know. I've got I've got the groove going.
So
You're in you're in flow.
Alpha five.
I mean, I'm almost tempted to v one
this now, to be honest. If
this worked, we could, like, we we could
naught point one it. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. For
sure. Alright. Let's grab release five,
SHA Summit.
Copy this. Uninstall. Reinstall. I mean that development
loop is not ideal I think, I still
think we're doing something slightly incorrect with how
crew wants us to work but
it's working for now. It is what we
haven't actually read their docs to be fair
so.
That's true. So let's uninstall,
and then verbs,
and then install, and then verbs.
That should work.
Okay. Oh, yeah.
Come on. Look at that. Hey. Let's scrape.
Engine x.
Oh, no. No.
What?
I don't understand.
That's
That should work.
How is it extracting that?
Okay. So how did it get known NGINX
one?
So we look at the old patch.
No, it was verb. It was verb, right?
Oh no, it was noun. No, was noun.
Yeah, verb should be here.
Shifting to
I think we,
it's that shift. What happens if you shift
twice and there's only one in the array?
Is that and we're just rejecting the last
one. Oh, maybe.
So it's shift one to get the known.
Shift to oh yeah. That you're right. There
was too many shifts. Shift one. That's what
I'm saying. Let's run this locally.
I'm not I
can't
reason about this from first principles because I
don't actually know what he's doing. I think
we just need a lot of print f
debugging.
Yeah. It worked locally. Yeah. How did we
break it?
But it gets one more argument, right, when
we're running
No. Because I'm passing in noun. Oh, you
are? Yeah.
Describe
nginx one.
Alright. That that is perfect.
So
let let's push it one more time and
then we'll wrap it up. We're kinda
getting towards the end of an hour and
a half. And as much fun as it
is Oh, wow. We've got a job to
do. Real jobs.
Yeah. First, we need to put back the
code to what I wrote because that was
correct and you need to publish that in
public.
And then
there we could we could call it.
That's
gonna hurt with that commit. Right? Okay. It
was the sarcasm. That's why I'm coming for
you, David. It
was the shade I got last time.
Re unrefactored,
Matt.
And I'll take it out of court. Oh,
thank you. Affects him Don't feel so needed.
David's.
The humiliation.
Right.
That was worth it.
Right. Alpha six six alphas in a day.
Right. So
let's get a I wish we had to
get some seed some seed funding for that.
We don't have a star yet. I'm really
disappointed in your audience. Come on.
No. I think it'll get hub star. This
is gold, pure gold.
Right. Imagine the amount of update notifications you
get Oh. Oh yeah. Just don't watch it.
That's probably a poor idea. But star of
the thing, please. So
we now have alpha six
and we wanna uninstall.
Install
key in
pods. Oh, come on.
There's something weird happening between us running this
locally versus what we're getting as the
so the plugins getting one less. That's what
it is.
So Oh, is it actually stripping it? Right.
Yeah.
Because remember, it's just it's just executing
our script. Of course. It is. But I
I assumed it would dump its own argument
array through. I didn't think it would okay.
So we just need to lose that first
the first shift. Yeah. Right. I thought it
was I thought it was copying its argument
array verbatim.
I'm sure we had evidence for that. Oh,
I don't know. I don't know.
We're now in alpha seven.
I don't know what the commit message is
for this fix.
Let's just do shrug emoji.
Yeah.
We'll go with this one.
Okay.
Try again.
That item was pretty decent.
I'm assuming it doesn't handle the skin tone
variance. That seems to be the problem.
Right.
There's tag seven.
I see now there's a window for someone
to have starved this and if it's not
you Matt, I mean, what are you even
doing here?
So. I mean, it's me because
I thought we needed some love.
Yeah. If it wasn't you, you were gonna
get called out for that, so I'm glad.
Right. Okay.
Now we have seven for redownload and release.
I really I I don't like this workflow.
No. We could I
mean, I don't think it's the workflow that's
expected of us. I think it's us doing
something.
I don't think we need we don't need
to install it every time. Right? We could
literally just overwrite that SIM link.
Yeah. Alright.
That's what's I'm sure it says. So can
pods.
Get. Should be the same.
There's bit of lag.
Yeah. I'm at Nail
biting for Eric. Oh, yeah.
Look at that.
That's so exciting.
Job done. Oh, the final test.
Exec.
Oh, yeah.
Nice. And it doesn't support exec.
Awesome.
Good work, team. Yeah. Let's
add. So that we add to the noun
verb. It's not a tag. It's not a
release. So this is just a chore.
Update it.
Crew manifest. I don't think the manifest should
probably live in this repository.
But for now,
we have a working plugin. I'm happy to
No. I mean, what what we haven't done
is publish it. Right? I guess publishing it
is gonna involve getting that manifest into the
central upstream
Yeah. There's a crew index
which Right. Which I assume means Yeah. We
need to PR or something into this.
Yeah. There we go. So this is just
Maybe this is the
canonical source.
Maybe it's not. I don't know.
We we could avoid the double commit thing
with with some GitHub action magic.
Well, don't think we need the double commit.
We just don't need that
Oh, we we just made the file. Yeah.
Yeah. The other repository just becomes the actual
the single source of it.
So let's
try we
we we want to submit that PR, like
I'll do that later. I don't think it's
quite ready.
Do mean it's not ready? Does it handles
pods and deployments.
We need that we should put a license
on it at least. You're right. Okay. Yeah.
Let's get that cleaned up and ready for
open source consumption.
We can fight on the license later. I'm
assuming we'll just go MIT though. So Oh,
yeah. Yeah. I just mean it's it's polite
to put to to give it to the
world. Or we could proprietor license it and
sell it.
I pay
nothing for that. Yeah. Yeah.
That was fun. I really enjoyed that. It
was.
I hope people watching that got some value
from understanding how a cube control plugin works.
The development cycle working with crew, I mean,
don't think we've nailed that. I think we
identified at the end there the reason we
have that weird thing. I'm not sure how
to upgrade a local plugin but there's definitely
stuff that is to get that a little
bit nicer.
And hopefully,
some people find this useful when we publish
it. Anything you'd like to add or finish
with there, Matt?
No. I don't think so. That was that
was a lot of fun. I might go
and write a couple of plugins. Thank you
very much for having me. No. My pleasure.
Thank you for joining me. Thank you.
I I really I'm looking forward to adding
a few more
nodes to this and actually using it in
my daily cube control journey. So anyway, that's
I'm gonna refactor all my shell this is.
Yeah exactly I can cut off so many
KPOs,
KPDs, all these different things. Yeah. Alright
anyway, thanks have a great day I'm gonna
actually do some real work now before I
get fired So I'll speak to you soon.
Cool. See you soon. Bye.